did you enjoy particularly about song  for Marion such a beautiful film isn't  it yeah well it's always it's always a  bonus when you get a wonderful script  really and it just felt well working  with an s orange mo you know it was like  a silver lined movie really and it felt  good I mean if so wonderful but easy  frankly but there's so many moving  moments in FL booked a key when vanessa  gets up and sings i mean did you have a  little deer in your own re at that  moment yeah she's just I mean I realized  that she'd had an almost amount of  tragedy in her life in the year prior to  the movie but i guess like all truly  great artist she just she just put it  into her work you know so when you're  working with her although it doesn't  visually appear that anything's  happening you're feeling enormous  amounts you know this there's an amazing  backstory going on so yeah it was I wish  yeah if I could just make movies like  that I'd be in good shape  you